Alexandra rayabichkina fulfills an
important role in her country's war
effort being a grandmother to her
grandchildren
displaced by the fighting around
marupole in the South she's now helping
the family make a new life north of Kiev
done
I know lots of people who are in the
same situation with young people
fighting and the grandparents taking
care of their grandchildren on the one
hand the war divides families and on the
other it brings families closer together
left to bring up her children by herself
their mother is now able to look for
work
support is the most important thing
there's no way we could manage without
her not just actual help but also moral
support more and more families in
Ukraine are having to rely on
grandparents
at this children's charity more than one
in ten of calls to their helpline are
from grandparents needing help with
children struggling to cope with the
absence of parents
the child will be anxious or cannot
sleep or ceases to communicate with
other children wakes up at night and
sees Horrors we have a lot of teenagers
who want to self-harm or think about
suicide young people need to build their
plans for a future and it's difficult to
plant anything in a war there's also
increasing concern among child welfare
groups about the long-term impact of
families being separated by War
effectively a generation of Ukrainian
children growing up with sometimes one
or both parents being absent from their
lives Nadia constantineevna has been
helping bring up her two grandsons most
of their lives
the last time they heard from their
mother she was in Russia and their
father was killed in the fighting last
year which also destroyed their home in
Sevilla Donetsk
we have nowhere to go we had a
five-story house that was completely
burnt down we were left in the basement
we will never get back what we had I
lost touch with my friend and I don't
know where they are now some of them may
be in occupied territories
even after this war is over families
across Ukraine will continue to suffer
the effects of it for a long time to
come Rob McBride Al Jazeera Keith